hello everyone this is future alana
letting you all know that uh as
the next episode of the podcast is one
of our live episodes that we do for
every 10 episodes
we have committed to doing it live on
tuesday the 27th
of april obviously at 12 30 p.m pacific
time
here on youtube or obviously if you're
listening to an audio service
youtube.com
slash carolinazad so we do it live and
then
we take the live down and we'll make it
private uh to
edit it so the audio levels are actually
proper in case you missed the live and
that will go up on friday because i
always have people ask what happened to
the live version
basically always gets taken down to be
republished later so
if you'd like to join us for a live
special please do we will see you on
tuesday
at 12 30 p.m pacific time and it will be
pretty much exactly an hour
we'll see you then if somebody
masturbates and they get caught
but they've got a really cool roommate
is it appropriate for that roommate to
say hey
you do you
i don't know how i didn't see where this
was going but
i'm back [ __ ]
my answer is yes i think that that is
appropriate yes that would be the
coolest roommate ever yeah
that'd be nice i've never walked in on
anybody masturbating but i don't
know what how are you supposed to react
to that what's the appropriate
oh man i don't know the weirdest it
would immediately go from the coolest to
the weirdest
if they just stayed they're just like
you want interviews you do you
there's a lot of ways that that i i
think that the ways that that
goes well are substantially outnumbered
by the awkward
well i imagine most people react with
the like oh oh oop sorry oh my god sorry
um i've had people walking on me while i
was on the bathroom in the bathroom on
the toilet before
that happened the john mulaney bit is so
good where he goes
our voice automatically changes to like
a
40s carnival person it's like someone's
in here
it's like we get the weirdest thing
come on show your hands you've never
like no one's ever
like your parents never walked in i was
like what were you doing
and they know that's ever happened no
that was almost australian but i also
know it's never happened to me
um but i also feel like it's maybe a
little bit easier for women to hide
yeah guys we're just slaving apes
it's just you don't really have too much
you sort of have to stop moving
it's not terribly difficult yeah what
are you doing i was reading a book
snapping i did i did the closest i've
ever had to that was
my mom once this is going weird
coming like just unannounced just
walking in the room once
um this was in high school
where my girlfriend and i we were in a
post-coital
place high school and she
my mom just came in and the way that the
way that my room was
was arranged was that there was right
next to the bed was a door to a closet
that had a kind of like line of sight
thing where if you just went the the 18
inches
from the bed to the closet you would be
completely out of
the line of sight from the door into the
bedroom you measured that [ __ ]
it was it well it was hiding in that
moment
it was like the escape hatch out of the
out of you know like into the bomb
shelter
because we both just scrambled and what
was hilarious
is that neither of us both of us was in
this very much like everyone for
themselves just
falling all over each other like george
costanza getting out of the kitchen when
it's on fire
you know just absolutely no you wouldn't
why were you not allowed to be
cuddling in bed dude well there was
oh you did say you were teenagers we
were it was that's the thing my parents
were totally
it was just the surprise my parents
didn't give a [ __ ]
it wasn't that we were cuddling in bed
it was it was two
uh disrobed essentially corpses lying on
top of the bed
uh and there was this moment where my
mom
she doesn't know how to react because it
was so shocking and we reacted so
instantly and so we're both just like
and then hiding kind of
essentially off camera from my mom's pov
as it were
and she just stands she doesn't know
what to do and yeah mac and cheese
that was exactly amazing that was that
was exactly what my mom was just like
well it's not a rational moment it's not
it's not like
thoughtful you just it's fight or flight
it's like i'm gonna die right now for
some reason
and so yeah my mom just stood there and
was like
i'll come back later i guess
or something and then the best part was
then like you know heart comes down and
you're like okay i guess
i guess i survived and took her home and
i'm sitting there at dinner and my mom's
just like
sitting there and finally just goes do
we need to talk about the
uncomfortableness or something like that
and i was like honestly
i think it's hilarious yeah and uh
and she was like okay because i was
really worried that you were very sort
of
traumatized or something and yeah it was
that was the closest i've ever
done you were traumatized that's a great
your mom's awesome
yeah i think your mom listens to this
show i hope your mom listens to this
episode and then somehow
like i wish your mom could call in right
now and go
that's not true here's what happened she
does my mom
first of all there was no girl
[Laughter]
and it was just him and some
transformers
and a broken gi joe and [ __ ] got weird
real fast
that's why she won't be calling the show
i would rather live in the illusion of
how i
told the story no it is actually very
sweet she sends me
uh regular updates of her thoughts on
the most recent
uh episodes of that i had no idea that
she was listening until we were probably
25 episodes in or something and then i
started getting the
so this i have a question about such as
like follow-ups and stuff and
that's cool my sister's been listening
because she's pregnant and she wants
the unborn child to hear my voice
so she's been listening to the show and
my mom's always what lengths is she
going to to achieve this
dare i ask to be fair it also means that
she's listening to all of you
so yeah
so here's what you need to know i'm the
dumb one
austin's the smart one okay alana is the
responsible one
and mike is a socialist
i like how mike is also just apparently
where is
mike hello everyone by the way hi mike
look i was gone last week
this is a solidarity downhill is that
what it is
if this is this this podcast has become
like survivor and
and yeah but how did i get voted back on
mike sacrificed himself maybe to give
you a slot
well uh anyway hello everyone um our
second week in a row that we're going to
have
youtube ad problems youtube's not going
to like this opening topic
welcome to play watch listen i'm a lot
of peace i'm a video game writer that's
awesome winter he's a video game poster
and that's troy becky
is a video game actor acta in general
um hey we're all we're all
i love you oh yeah what made you say
that i'm curious
i try not to introduce you as video game
actor um
i i but i think i i have done it out of
habit because i say video game before
everyone else
but i thought about it you do a lot of
stuff that that one's like but you've
also been a cinematics director and you
just did
yeah the list is long i was doing an
animated show
look oh dude that shows dope if you
haven't watched it it's really good dota
we just know season two on netflix
congrats it's grope
it's grope it's great it's grope groping
is uh
yeah yeah you probably probably
shouldn't be groping out here um
i look i wanna cuz this is look the
reason why the four of us are together
is because of our place in this
specific sphere right it's it's we all
have our kind of like four corners of
of how we hit this industry we all have
a mutual love for this industry
and an affinity and we've all been
successful in this industry
um it makes sense for us to go like
here's why this guy is here talking
about this thing
even though a lot of times we don't ever
talk about that thing sometimes we talk
about that thing at all that's true but
you know
it it i i was thinking about this
literally this morning i was like
does it does it bother me should it
bother me why does it bother me
however people identify me you know what
i mean like do they go
troy he's a voice actor it's like dude
if that's how you know me
why does that have to what i have to
correct and trust me i've been guilty of
doing that but
i was like excuse me i don't act with
just my voice like why the [ __ ] does it
matter if you if you go
okay great i've never played that game i
didn't know that and doesn't change the
fact that i like you so i've really i
love that you
the second that i like abandoned that
notion and go it doesn't matter you can
call me whatever you want he's like oh
hey you're the
fortnite guy i'm like yeah that's that
that's how you know me
great or that's all right you're in that
shitty movie striking range i'm like
you need to get out more naturally that
happens to me all the time like i think
a lot of people
think i am a youtuber full-time or like
a streamer full-time
like you're like a lot nope yeah you do
a lot of it though
it makes sense like you you're not
enough to do it full time the the the
twitch one i always get like people were
saying that to me before i had ever
ever uh even partnered on twitch meeting
i had never made any
money at all and they were like
full-time twitch streamer alana pierce
what
um but it's not other people's job to
know that if they see you on a platform
they're like that's what you do and i'm
like if that's how you know me that's
okay i'll only ever point out um
with some frequency that i don't
consider myself to be
a full-time content creator because i'm
not um but i feel like i bring that up
often
for a multitude of reasons one is
because it's an indication of how
frequently i should be uploading things
and what things i should be uploading
like if you think i'm full-time then
there's an expectation that i should be
doing a certain amount
and b quality it's like some of this
stuff is just
something i did in the 10 minutes that i
had spare that day
um so i feel like it's an important
thing to reiterate is like this is not
what i do
this is not a thing that i'm committed
to doing with any particular frequency
or quality
it's just something that i continue to
do for fun and the minute that work is
too busy or whatever
this stuff all drops like all of the
youtube stuff drops my my video uploads
go down
um twitch streaming stops it's all you
know it's not permanent do you
feel that that has helped kind of
managing those expectations because
you are remarkably um successful at this
like
there's a lot of p john reisinger has
this he said this offhand and i've
quoted him so many times saying this
he's like there's some of us that are
out here seriously trying to carve space
and i was like what a great analogy or
metaphor for that
and there are there are a lot of people
that are
that have your chair and all aspects of
that both
literal and and metaphorical and are
trying to carve space and do what you do
they're the the second that whatever
like you uh i watched you do the
resident evil demo
which we can talk about that if you want
to yeah um [ __ ] it's creepy
but yeah dude soups soups creeps um
the i'm trying guys
let that slide did ya just walk right
through that
but what's funny is i have committed to
it and half pulled the eject button
halfway through so if you listen if i
can go soon
jesus anyway the fact that you've been
able to what are you at
you're at um 11 billion subscribers what
do you have
550 that's a [ __ ] ton [ __ ] ton that's
what i meant a [ __ ] ton
sure so um there are people that
upload with more frequency and and or or
click all of the
or tick all the boxes that you're
supposed to take in order to have
successful algorithms and youtube's but
whatever
they haven't yeah they haven't hit that
do you think that
besides the fact that you're i'm follow
me on these tangents
pen right here left turn for for a brief
period
of time when i was in texas during the
poker boom
um i ran a company being the
entrepreneurial spirit that i
am that put poker tables into bars now
in texas there is no gambling allowed
you to go north or
east in order to go to oklahoma to go
play at the
windstar casino or you go to shreveport
and be able to
gamble on the river it was it was
literally off you had to cross over a
bridge and then you could gamble
so what we would do is we would do you
were you weren't gambling it was for
money
but you would do a quote chip rental so
twenty dollars got you
a thousand dollars worth of tokens chips
to play with
and you were renting those things but
what we would do is every six weeks we
would take the top ten people from the
leaderboard and we would throw them into
a tournament for a big screen tv
you would not buy into that tournament
because your position over the last six
weeks would have secured your spot
tracking so we would go to a bar and go
we want to put
a poker table in your in your bar and
they're like no stupid no one's going to
do it it's like if you just trust us
give us
give us you know six weeks and if it
doesn't you know if you don't see your
bar sales increase
then we'll we'll take yours like well
we're not going to pay for the table
like no no we provide the table tips
chairs and dealer
and they were like great okay go for it
and it's like oh by the way we're going
to give 10
10 of the cut we got it to the point we
were doing about a grand a night and we
were running four poker tables across
dallas
so we were doing really with zero
overhead all we had to do is you know
pay guarantee our dealers that we would
pay them a certain amount
and what we found was that typically
women dealt better men stayed longer
and it wasn't just like you get a hot
chick in there
and you'll be great the second that that
girl can't split pots
or she can't count cards faster than the
person who's in front of them
they did not like her so it's not i
don't the reason why i'm coming back to
the main thing
the reason why i don't buy into the fact
is like you get a pretty girl on twitch
or youtube and they're going to get
subscribers it's not true
you the reason why you're successful is
because you know you're [ __ ]
and you're able to speak to it with a
level of
not only competency but just um i'm
gonna use your word expertise
that most people cannot and you back up
what you say and you're not a tourist
you like
you know the thing there's more to it
than that in that um
experience as well well and years of
channel but i actually
the the reason that i actually have the
subscribers i have certainly not because
i'm a woman because of the amount of
people who
refuse to watch my content because i'm a
woman and openly tell me that every day
right like weird that's why there are no
big
uh i think i might be the biggest gaming
channel in terms of
women speaking about games editorially
other than girlfriend reviews
um i don't know of any women who are
successful in the editorial space
uh but they come from the companies i
work for so i have a lot of subscribers
because i've worked for channels and
companies that have had
millions and millions of people
following them it's not something that i
built organically
um but it's also that because of my job
in media i've had early access to things
access to people like you access to
information like one of the biggest
booms i had was when i played red dead
redemption 2 early
as media at the time meaning that i
would have been one of the only people
who played it early and made a youtube
video about it that wasn't one of the
mainstream media outlets so it's like
that stuff it's really it's really the
companies i've worked for
i'd argue that it's still organic though
because if you haven't stood out
you know like sure there are there i
wouldn't have done it without those
companies is all i'm saying
but that's like that's like none of us
would have done what we have without
someone
someone was a benefactor for all of us
right 100
this this is like saying you know
this would be like if harrison ford were
deflecting
uh his career or trajectory because he
was just one of the cast of star wars
you know it's like sure you you were a
very memorable part of the cast you know
not to not to try to inflate your ego
but i think it's it's
it's wrong to say harrison ford it's
okay it's wrong to say
wait is she harrison ford
i confuse them all the time so i just
thought i'd make sense
all women and harrison ford just broadly
interchangeable
i saw you were awesome in air force one
by the way yeah um
okay get off my plane give me give me
back my family
um yeah i i think that yes it is it is
completely fair
to credit those
platforms but obviously if you were
you know if you were pulling in if you
were dead air in those rooms on those
shows
it wouldn't have so that's why i say it
is organic because you you were like hey
i'm not trying to dismiss the things
that i think that i do well either
but it's just you know i didn't start as
a youtuber i started in media my first
writing gigs were
all in print there's like magazines so
even those had a following
um and then i was on international tv
and radio in australia so
that adds into it and then you add an
ign and then you add in resources
it's just a bunch of of places that have
a lot of people so it's um
that's that's i don't i wouldn't have
the channel that i have if i didn't
have those people but then like now it's
also become friends like
you know the amount of people that i get
to work with um but i do think that i'm
in a very unique position of
having very candid conversations with a
lot of people who work in the industry
um who i'm friends with again like you
guys that are willing to do that on
youtube where they wouldn't necessarily
for a lot of other youtubers
and that's the thing that i intend to do
a bit more of is uh like i'm planning to
do a stream
with um blue bit team about the medium
pretty soon about some of their
storytelling choices and that's the
thing that like maybe they would usually
offer to
other media uh that i'm having a
conversation with them about doing
on the youtube channel and i don't know
i i really enjoy
what i get to do because it's not
something that i take super seriously
and to to bring it back to troy's
original point
i do think a very common way that people
have trouble growing as content creators
is by trying
too hard to be what they think is
successful and not just make the stuff
that they want to make
dude i have if this year has taught me
anything
really the last four years it's how
um number one i i have
zero desire to um
compete with or try to please the
algorithm
so it's not what i want to do and that's
not knocking the people that do
there's a lot of people like
jacksepticeye is a dear friend
and what he does is he has been able to
he
busted his ass for three years in in in
some ways in a non-healthy way that
he'll tell you about
but he also was able to go i'm going to
rise above the den and then once i get
there do something with it
and he's the one that was the first
person that i saw i'm
not not not saying that nobody else had
done it but he's the one that i saw that
that was like i want to say something
and his message of positivity and brian
and amelia deck are the same way
it's like if you can hear my voice if if
that's all that you get from this i just
want to let you know that you're okay
and that you're loved and that there can
be a good
spot for this it doesn't have to all be
vitriolic and and
[ __ ] slinging so i i
i recognize that that's what i want to
do
but because it's a side gig and grace
frick who's a fellow australian
from adelaide you know grace hey
guys come mate oh yeah she can hear you
not here to [ __ ] spiders
i'm i'm i'm saying i'm talking the same
way you are
um in my head grace is awesome
and and she's she's kind of our
community manager for later and she said
um i forget sometimes that this is your
sidekick
and i was like yeah i really want to do
something with this but i don't have the
desire to
to do what you're supposed to do in
order to grow it and maybe i should i
don't know but i've i've definitely
i've made a lot of mistakes this this
year about how
what a youtube quote youtube channel is
supposed to look like i mean i would be
happy if my youtube channel never grew
again
that like right now i don't want it to
be any bigger
stay how it is 100 miami right now
what's the disadvantage of growth like
what is because it's not like you're
having to maintain a community on
discord
from it or things like that so what's
the what's the scale
issue if it let's say it jumped to a
million followers because of
this episode um
i think that the the community that i
have right now generally like
understands the weird schedule like that
i will often upload something at 11 pm
because i'm editing after i finish my
work hours that's super weird but i'll
often
like just go live on something as soon
as it's it's edited
um so the expectation is manageable but
i also think like you know the higher
number is an increase in toxicity and
i do have like things i try to stick to
with my channel which is
uh but you don't go wading into the
weeds on that stuff
much that at least doesn't seem like it
from here that like even if it was a
ten-fold increase in toxicity if you're
basically
just not allowing yourself to go into
that i do read my youtube comments
um but i do also have mods um
i see it's just the bigger you are the
the
more expectation there is essentially
and i'm like i'm very happy to have this
little
or i know that i'm making content that a
lot of people don't want to hear like
i'm very actively aware that that's the
thing that i'm routinely doing is like
all the big gaming youtubers are
going to be very angry at a certain
publisher at a certain dev and i very
much try to give my perspective as
someone who has worked in the industry
for a decade
and that's a thing that not many people
do and not many people want to hear
which means the bigger that i would get
with that just the more angry people
would be about it i'm like happy to like
have
a group of people that you know often
strangers will still find my videos
through seo or whatever
um but who understand the perspective of
that but i try to only make something if
it's positive so if i feel like very
happy about it or i'm excited about it
like i do unboxings not because i think
they're good content but because i get
very excited about opening toys
so i do those because i'm like i'm
really excited i'm going to share this
excitement with people because i just
have always loved that
um not because i think that they're
interesting just because they're fun
and otherwise it's about trying to be
informative or helpful so if i can
provide information that i don't think a
lot of people on youtube are providing i
will do that
i will not talk about a topic if i feel
like everyone has spoken about it to
death and shared every take on it that i
already agree with and i'm like
everyone else has got you covered go
look at someone who can make a fancier
video essentially
that's what i try to see do you also
feel that there is a um
there's a level of once you start
growing then it's like
like again the level of expectation
that's there it's like now we're
everybody wants to be a part of
something big there there's there's
different people that love to be on
they're the early adopters they're the
hipsters
in the truest sense of like i was into
it before it was cool
and then there are those people that a
lot of times those are the ones that
kind of
have a tendency to to die off quicker
once it becomes a successful
thing because they were like no i was i
was i listened to it on vinyl with
headphones you know like
that's what they wanted and then all of
a sudden it becomes this big thing is
like ah
i want to go find the next thing that i
can they're the growers they're the
growing part of the community
and then they're the people that come in
and they don't remember
or they weren't familiar with the way it
started
and so then that's their level of
expectation fun house
been through that hall yeah and then the
next thing you was like well now we've
got
this this is a real thing we've had to
grow to be able to kind of
keep up with the demand and now it's a
thing now we're responsible for people
and it becomes this runaway successful
hit
i remember talking to sean he's like man
i just miss
being able to do some videos sometimes
just like
it becomes such a not a chore an
obligation
but you it's the same thing of like i
always equate everything to music
and all we wanted to do was be on the
road
and then we got there and then it was
like it's not what i want to do
and i have friends that are professional
touring musicians
and i don't think i've ever met a
musician that loves that lifestyle
it's so brutal it's brutal i feel like
it's always spoken about like
romanticized like it's the ideal
not not the side guys the the the people
that sideman
for you know uh big acts right so it's
it's like a solo artist
um that play in the so-and-so band
kind of thing that is a person that is
sleeping in a six-foot coffin
overnight but the band too that's the
thing it's it's relentless for them like
they obviously
reap the biggest like the headliner
they'll reap the biggest
windfall from it but it's still my my
orchestrator susie
did a gig of something like a year and a
half of conducting
uh uh evanescence essence and lindsey
stewart
sterling did it very good they did a
team-up
tour for like a year all over the world
where it was like you know kind of
out goth each other go it was like
i don't think i'd ever call lindsay
sterling goth but uh
the there's some aspects of it the vibes
the um
the um uh the the
the show was you know kind of an
orchestral hybrid thing so susie was
there to conduct the orchestra
and um she add to the
equation that susie also was with like a
freaking three-week-old child or
something
so she's like pumping and nursing and
like always carving out like space for
but she was saying that you know it was
just
it was absolutely relentless of you know
roll into town
crews getting a stage ready to go you
know 10 000 people or whatever show up
they they do a quick sound check and
and then they do the performance and
then they're on the bus because
the next morning they're gonna wake up
you know two towns over
and do it all again and it's basically
that
you know for months and it's just
it's relentless and it's the same you
know it's the same music same set list a
lot of times
so there's a certain amount of like okay
how do we make this crowd feel like this
is our first time doing this show
you know that's why i look at it that's
why i look at broadway actors and you
know like
you see them on a friday night you're
like this is the 12th time they've done
this in the last week and you just think
and they're and they're giving it their
all because they realize you're
fresh you're the you're the like virgin
soil that's coming in they're
completely unexposed to this and they
have a
they have a certain responsibility to to
give you something that that is as if
it's new to everyone and that to me i
feel very spoiled
like i got i actually have a conducting
uh gig in a couple weeks conducting some
music from
from journey congratulations big first
for you that's huge i know well it's
been forever since i've been on stage
uh and they were like our budget is thin
i was like i don't care
i'll fly myself there if it i don't care
if it's also a stream
yesterday messaged a friend who's a
bartender and was like i will dj for
free
i miss it so much you guys don't even
have a dance floor
just let me play some house in the
background yeah that's completely
no for sure but that's such a different
thing it's so spoiling you go in
you rehearse you perform and then i'm
and then i'm done until the next
one it's the idea of like okay now again
and again and again for sometimes like i
went remember seeing
elton john a couple years ago as part of
his big farewell
tour and it was like a three-year tour i
mean it's
a three-year doing the same basic show
more or less
every night do you think that's better
or worse than the people in vegas who
have the residencies where they do the
same thing every night in the same place
it's a different side of the same coin
like yeah it's just brutal
to me to me it's like if you if you go
in and are anything even remotely
close to wowed you should
realize how amazing it is that they can
wow you
knowing that it's their thousandth time
yeah
doing it i i remember when i first moved
to l.a
my the first like 30 days in la for me
were just a fever dream of
of where i found myself and who i found
myself with
and my first concert
at the bowl was roger waters doing the
wall
and i looked at him and he
watched the crowd sing along
to whatever song they were playing with
childlike wonder and was
was legitimately it looked surprised
that people knew
you guys know this one i was like you've
been playing that album
for 40 years and i think that there's
some people that
live on stage like that that is just i
i'm
i'm a consummate performer and in some
ways
that is my better nature and it is my my
inner demon
because the same thing that drives me to
perform on a stage
can also be something that drives me to
perform in front of
people and and allow myself to not be an
authentic person and what i've realized
is that
the best shows that i've ever had i
someone told me a story
at coachella that paul mccartney
headlining coachella and he's doing hey
jude
and he forgot the words
and he just looked down and he was like
and he couldn't believe he's like i have
no idea what this verse is
and the crowd started singing him back
and i was like that wasn't a moment for
those people was a moment for paul
mccartney
and for me to have that yeah dude for me
to ha
to have that moment of just like
real and authentic um vulnerability
is is to me what makes the that's what
i'm always drawn to right you know one
of my favorite concerts that i went to
in that same exact vein
that so one time at the greek
which is kind of like the little mini
that's not
i don't know if you've ever been to the
greek uh alana in in kind of uh los
feliz
uh area that's that's um i think but i
don't think i've been
it's it's much smaller than the bowl but
it's a similar vibe it's outdoor
amphitheater
the bowl either didn't that close wasn't
that one of the ones that got
did no no no no no it was just closes
like
yeah they go uh winter is orchestra and
summers like the concerts i think right
i thought that that was like i saw that
somewhere in the arc light news
the henry fonda no it's not the font the
font is the small inside the ford
theater is another amphitheater on the
other side of the 101 that's
great yeah the ford is also very cool
did did uh
did uh journey there once and and it was
so so cool
yeah identified done a couple shows
there and it's such a cool it because it
feels
it's like red rocks in colorado but uh
but one tenth that size it's much more
intimate
but anyway so at the greek a number of
years ago my ex
said hey you want to go to a concert
this friday and it i can't remember the
specifics if it was kind of sight unseen
but you know every now and again i would
go to a show with her that was not the
norm as somebody who tends to skew
a little bit towards uh you know
either really esoteric acts or just
going to see my friends or like
the la phil or whatever so this of all
people was
sheryl crow oh yeah dude not someone i
would have sought out and it ended up
being such an incredible
show because she was sick and she was
like she comes out on stage and goes i'm
i got a cold my my voice can't
can't really hold up but i thought you
know what
these people come i'm gonna come so just
bear with me
and so her voice would crack in the
middle of the song and
you know she'd sit and then hit a note
and she'd just look at the crowd and be
like
and everyone would cheer and lose their
mind like we got you you got that story
do you know what i mean oh yeah it was
authentic yeah and she you could see her
not feeling like oh
you know she wasn't beating herself up
but there wasn't an arrogance either of
like
i can feed these plebeians whatever
[ __ ] i want and they'll it was like it
was like we're all gonna have
a moment for the next couple of hours
and just just bear with me and it was so
charming and she [ __ ] up a lot
not [ __ ] up but her voice wouldn't
sustain it and um
and she would just laugh it off and it
was so i was like i came out of this a
sheryl crow fan
because i just saw a real person you
know and
i've never heard someone say walk away
from a concert and said
i heard someone so and so play they're
like i saw them play it's about
that song being performed live no matter
what that looks like
um i had a friend tell me a story about
upstate new york
um early early 80s matter of fact maybe
late late 70s
um and they they would always go to this
this place to see
like you know whatever band's coming
through and there was a bad snowstorm
and so the people that got up there
early was like eight people 10 people or
whatever
we're gonna be able to see the band and
the band was like [ __ ] this man this is
not what we showed up for we showed up
to
you know have a packed house probably
two 250 300 people could be in that club
and they were not gonna come out but
it's like what else are we gonna do and
so they just walked out and they're like
we're gonna do the same show we did for
eight people that we would have done for
everybody
and and so they got to basically hang
with these people i feel like i'd prefer
that
that band was the police wow [ __ ]
i know like uh dave grohl uh
often um will you know sort of
just talk a lot like just you know
people go to see
dave roll play but he'll just sit down
and have candid conversations and
they're not the same every show
it's like just segments where he's just
sitting and just talking to an audience
people seem to really like that like
i've only ever heard really good
feedback rather than he didn't play the
songs back to back they seem to be like
i was moved by this and
and i feel like that's a more valuable
experience i one time
saw troy's favorite randy newman uh
and
[Laughter]
[Music]
i don't know excuse me i have no i don't
read that at all the sentence
structure with randy newman to me is
just like a a
like it's he's can't formulate a
straight if it dances
you do it all right you know i
you know may i remind you that he also
wrote this
come on shout out listen you can't deny
this is a perfect piece of songwriting
okay
well it was until you [ __ ] it up
pretty bad
there's something very wild about having
troy baker
do an impression and then austin wintery
goes shut the [ __ ] up
to play piano and i'll
remind you saying that which showed that
like if you
if you you know he's not a great singer
obviously it's part of the charm of of
some of his more ridiculous songs but
like when he sits down to write
a song like that and then they give it
to someone like her it's like
this guy's a genius but anyway that's
all his
his uh his songwriting ability is he
captures something in such a relatable
and tangible way
and i actually really do i like his
voice especially on songs like that to
where it is
it's the same thing with tom waits tom
waits has
the worst singing voice ever
and all i want to do is listen to it all
the time well that's the thing it
depends
great singer i think is is just probably
subjective but i would consider a great
singer to be someone who
conveys something to me effectively you
don't have to have you know a beautiful
singing voice but if i can feel the
emotion in their words whatever that
emotion is and like listening to
randy newman does give me a certain
sense of usually positivity i feel
like and nostalgia and whimsy delivers
everything
there's a big difference to me there's
there's kind of multiple randy newmans
because never mind the fact that he's
also this composer who writes this
you know pretty astonishing or
orchestral music for
scores and stuff but as a songwriter he
kind of you know there's the wholesome
randy newman that's like toy story like
what i just played from toy story 2.
and and then um and all the other kind
of pixar stuff but then there's also
this
very kind of like dark americana
um that's what made him famous long
before all the rest of it you know
especially in the 70s where like he has
a song that's never talked about as one
of his greats but to me it's just one of
these heartbreaking and
amazing songs it's called my country
and and he where he's basically just
describing
um get out of my
country
that's it you have to stop youtube's
going to demonetize us you're too
pitched
it's true it's true now listen to these
lyrics i just looked them up to make
sure i quote them right
here's the here's the lyrics of what i'm
taught where he's like he's basically
like
i'm at home in my country
despite this like this is what he's
saying the
he says um in the the
in the verse he says picture room with a
window sofa and some chairs a television
turned on for the night
picture a woman two children seated a
man lying there their faces softly
glowing
in the light this is my country and
these are my people
this is the world i understand and i
know i'm like the back of my own hand
like that's such a sort of sad and
almost
uh harsh statement of like this
you know this family sort of zombies in
a dark room staring at the tv but he's
like this is my country
and it's not in this in this way it's
not like
aspirationally you know let's all go
lift ourselves up or that you know he's
basically just like
i'm one of them you know and there's a
line here that says feelings might go
unexpressed i think that's probably for
the best dig too deep who knows what
you'll find
yeah damn dude yeah that's what i'm
saying he's no joke so
the reason i brought him up because he
did a show where it was just him on the
piano
and probably a thousand people in the
audience so it's a fairly
you know good-sized theater and i went
this was in high school i went with my
dad
and he goes um he just sat at the piano
and goes what do you want to hear
and people just started shouting out
songs and he just kind of
listened for whatever he heard and he'd
start playing and there were a few times
where he'd start playing one
and then he go honestly this one's no
good what else he just stopped you know
and then he would just
and he'd move on and then it was it was
it was so endearing it was just like
what we're talking about where i felt
like
i hung out with him you know yeah dude
i've had two
two concerts well a couple couple of
those i've had a handful of concerts
like that where
people that i've waited my whole life to
see um jeffrey gaines if you don't know
who that is
is one of them he's this amazing
singer-songwriter from
uh detroit and i waited 10 years and he
finally played
gypsy tea room which is the smaller club
to the gypsy ballroom in dallas
and i was one of like 20 people that
were there
and he's kept looking at me like what is
that because i was just wrapped i was on
every
and i asked him i was like you didn't
play this song he's like no man not
every night gets that song
i got to hang out with him it's cool um
jeff goldblum
seeing him play piano you really want to
do that you have to go
oh so do that at the dresden it's
available no it's the rock
well in in silver lake the lake of
silver
uh it's if if they you know make it
through this and if he goes back and
does it
he's um this was before like his
everyone who's i've ever talked to has
gone to see him is just like
high as a kite after they just love him
to death dude
he's he's incredible he does the same
thing as randy newman's like what do you
want to hear
i um this is always so goddamn
this is this is very telling of me but
michael w smith
uh for people who grew up listening to
um
just some of the worst versions of music
uh ever
um i i saw michael w smith was like
the crossover christian artist into
mainstream
and he would sell out arenas and it was
a
big deal and and very successful um and
he came out drupal murr
he went quarterback god damn it
oh there's a south pike ref south park
south park lately
good for you it's just a gift to the
world isn't it it is i got
real integrity though you guys i got
real boy with tegrity i know
it's okay die hards are still with it
but he goes off this big tour
and then he does like this one little
like church gig and there was you know
a bit large church but it was still just
this church thing and he goes
this is the moment he goes i this is not
my band these are my friends it was like
gary chapman was on he it was it was
like the all-star band he was like
i had this moment on tours like this is
not what i should be doing it's like
i've kind of lost myself
and i wanted to bring it back to just me
playing music with my friends and he
goes
what do you guys want to hear and both
the words if it would have been a speech
balloon were still
forming and he said it and i was about
eight rows back and i
jumped up and i was like all i needed to
say and he stands up at the piano
it was like who said that and it's from
his first album
and i was like it was me he was like how
do you know that song is like it's the
first lp that i ever bought
and it's the if michael w smith two and
huh did he play it hell yeah i did he
was like but the best part he goes
because gary you remember this one he's
like absolutely because gary chapman's
saying on he's like okay guys
he starts calling out chords and he
played it they all played it live and
was like
i get to watch this thing happen it's
like the song that i always wanted to
hear it sounds like you were watching a
rehearsal
okay but yeah but all these guys are
like studio cats and so they can be like
yeah it's gonna be there's you know
four bar you know blues bar change and
what the bullets was
anyway i do love those moments this is
what i have when mike biffle
by the way we should let people know
might be yeah to go back to what this
conversation originally was
um mike's not here uh
mikey didn't join her but then left
because he's having internet issues so
it looks like mike is not joining us for
this episode uh that we've just had one
long preamble
isn't he though isn't mike still here
he's always there in our hearts a little
socialist
you know i i feel him i feel him
in many places by the way just kills i
love so much that the socialist is the
guy that
owns the company and has the employees
he's the
[Laughter]
yeah it's just just beautiful i
uh it's like elon musk and just right
below it is
mike bethel moneybags mike um i'm i'm
gonna boost
the austin winter retweet if you haven't
gotten down on the
please caption this there's a great shot
just a still that that austin got
of uh it's mike bethel ben andak and me
uh while we're i guess austin was one
taking the picture
and it's just a beautiful opportunity
for people to give us
[ __ ] and i don't know why it's the joy
that you need in your life right now
you need it more than the purple iphone
how about that you need it more
that was i was gonna say um because i
was also tagged in this but it doesn't
matter if it's not
i might like go through and pick you
know
particularly funny caption and then send
them some play watch listen much
please dude oh he thought that we might
do that so i can tell you because
the idea is that ben is he's playing
you're either you're playing him or he's
playing you it's one or the other
it's a really good picture but it's the
it's the origin of
the origin of play watch listed in so
many respects because that was troy
recording hacks uh two years ago
yesterday
for john wick john [ __ ] there you
yeah it's go uh um
so what i wanted to actually talk about
today verbal iphone
45 minutes in no was actually the news
that broke and we're not actually going
to talk about the news it's just a
question i wanted to ask you guys
um that overwatch director jeff kaplan
announces departure from blizzard after
19 years
um this really just broke right before
the show which never happens
yeah we're always like way later so
breaking news on play watch listen we go
live with alana pierce how about this
one
yeah you know that one abc news tonight
captain who began his tenure in 2002
okay we're gonna we're gonna
request do you need that do you need i
need you to know you know i'm going to
say
either randy newman or john williams
it's nbc the nbc nightly nbc night
leader
okay so do we want to start again when
does the piano come in is that before or
after troy
and then i read the news it's the intro
it's the intro it's
okay so do you do your music
we go live with alana pierce and it was
john williams
shut up austin go ahead we're live
alana you're live thank you kaplan began
his tenure at blizzard in 2002
quickly joining the world of warcraft
team as a designer and eventually
becoming game director
on the mmo announcing his departure on
twitter kaplan wrote i am leaving
blizzard entertainment after 19
years amazing years it was truly the
honor of a lifetime to have the
opportunity to create worlds and heroes
for such a passionate audience
troy what's the word on the street about
this uh thank you alana what we're
hearing
is that uh kaplan of course making his
exit
a surprise uh no one knowing that this
was of course coming from the inside
uh what we are rumored to believe of
course speculative at this point we'll
continue
to keep tabs on this as we go along
thank you uh austin wintery on the line
here
i do have a question for you i thought
what i do love is that when people on
the street they they can just like
didn't say anything standing on the
street here of course
uh we can feel the winds uh uh both of
change and and literally the wind
uh here on this blustery day uh no one
uh being able to comment
uh yet but of course speculation will
continue
say it in that voice it just sounds
official i love i love you're basically
the the family guy
uh the biker dude that you know andrew
it's a great way to stay in shape
um so yeah jeff kaplan left blizzard and
what i wanted to ask you guys
um i don't have experience with this
unless you count maybe
bruce leaving funhouse which was a
pretty significant culture change but
have you ever been
working on a project and how to direct a
leave or someone in a very
high significant position leave and how
much of an impact does that actually
have on a project in the games industry
like obviously kaplan 19 years at
blizzard has been hugely influential at
the company
but i mean just like you know overwatch
2 this will probably affect
um but i just mean on like a even on a
smaller level if you have someone who is
like very
instrumental to a project leave what
tends to be the impact
on a on a video game i mean
i i've i've experienced it i don't if
someone leaves mid project overwatch is
a different thing yeah that that's you
know
most people are gonna are gonna um
[Music]
depart once it ships everything kind of
calms down
like thank you everybody um
overwatch is a little bit different
because of course it's it's going to be
an
ongoing thing so that would never happen
right
um i
if i remember talking to somebody who
had been at a company for 18 years
and i was like what have you learned he
was like no one should ever be in the
same position with the same company for
18 years
um there is just there comes a point
where it's like
i need to go off and do something else
i've done everything that i can do here
um i saw someone recently say um
and i i think i fully agree with this
that unless
uh you're at a company unless you're
learning or earning you shouldn't be
there
so there are like you know earning a lot
of money or learning a lot i tend to go
with the learning a lot
uh you know someone could offer me a lot
of money to stay and i wouldn't do it
like but if you're not doing either of
those things then you're not really
well but i think you could also flip
that word and not just be
earning i'm making a lot of money
because i think that could be a terrible
thing too it's like it's a gilded cage
but if you're earning the company a lot
of money like
if you're being able to generate a lot
of revenue so the company can grow
um or you know what i'm really doing
right now is i'm learning but learning
and learning i think it's a great maxims
because
depending and that's transcendent to any
industry yeah
i learned a lot by working at dry
cleaners i learned about working with
people i learned about
customer service and that was not going
to be anything that was
directly relatable to the industry that
i would be in
um i've you know i came in after amy
left uncharted and so that was something
that happened in the middle of a project
and it was
it had huge impact here's someone who
has been with naughty dog
not 19 years but a long time i think it
was 10 to 12 years at that point
um and had shepherded them into
a whole new era with with uh
quite possibly the most successful ip to
for for them
and and for certainly across the games
most awarded um
and then all of a sudden that person who
was there who was
who is the face of it you know there's
there's it
that's what i think people don't realize
is that
and everybody who's in that position of
a creative director would look and go
it's not me i'm just out here in front
talking to you
it's the scores of people the hundreds
of people the five
people that are behind me that we all
make this game together
and that's why i i really have to
commend it if he was here i would say
the same thing
um i really commit mike bithell that he
is constantly going
it's the company it's yeah and i
remember
i for like a rat present i gave
neil um or actually i think it was early
on
i special ordered a director's chair
when when he became our director uh a
special ordered a director's chair for
him
that's very cute uh it's very cute i
thought
um and we're like go ahead man just you
know try it out we
open it up and he sat in it for a second
and goes okay
and he got up and i don't think he's
ever sat in it since
and
it was a terrible present it was he was
like and i've realized this now that
um i worked with a director in um
not particularly in my opinion a good
director but a solid director
and his put it this way his chair on set
was the cleanest and the most
unused um and he was like i'm
he was 68 years old 70 when he was
directing us and
he he would first in last out and
he's the director is the person that
should be constantly
in motion constantly doing something and
so
i i believe in the notion of um of a
director who's
the face they're like who do we talk to
it's you but he's gonna go
no no no no it's also this person and
this person and this person and this
person
so i can't think that that
decision came lightly or haphazardly
i think i'm sure it was um
decision to leave for sure that stuff's
especially because uh i know that at
least in the old days
blizzard would always give you really
cool [ __ ] at the various milestones like
if you were there for five years 10
years 20 years
and it was usually like at 19. that
exactly like it better be a damn good
reason because
they give you like custom you know like
orc armor kind of [ __ ] like
like a sword that's been forged by a
blacksmith like they have really cool
milestone gifts for their really
long-term employees
at least they used to i have a friend
who was there for many years and and got
like a
like a helm after 15 years or so some
companies do like watches and stuff but
yeah i mean you definitely can't let
that make you stay at a
company like i'm i have no doubt that uh
jeff who i've met and has always been
very kind and very you know excitable um
didn't put a lot of thought into it i
just uh yeah i just wasn't sure really
like
you see a lot of speculation about the
idea of things being doomed as soon as
one particular person leaves and i would
say in my experience working at
companies that are all giant teams that
that
doesn't feel true um but that is
certainly an immediate fear and you know
they did mention uh the development of
overwatch too
because he was director on overwatch 2
has passed
to aaron keller
it's it's it's so i
i will add i was going to say when you
mentioned the
earning or learning my agent has a
version of that which is i i love
now it's more applicable i think to
freelancers because you're looking at a
series of sprints
throughout your as a freelancer as
opposed to like okay am i going to be
here for 10 years i think that
learning or earning is probably more
accurate for that model for the the
long-term investment potential but
but um so mileage may vary as it were
but
but her sort of triangle of criteria she
says every job you take
like when we're talking something shows
up and we talk about it
there's always it has to at least have
one of these three but ideally two or
all three which is good for the
wallet which is the earning obviously
like if it's just
garbage you know if it's gonna
especially in my world
there's a real potential to have things
cost money and actually lose money on a
project if i'm investing in a bunch of
musician recordings and things like that
and i'm actually coming out in the red
so there's the is it good for the wallet
um is it good for the career
like this is just such a high profile
thing that
that you know it will it will your name
will end up in front of people in in
a way that's good for the overall health
of your career
you know is there is there that aspect
to it and then the third one
is is it good for the soul you know is
it good for
is it something that you just have to do
because it it's feeding something that
needs
to be fed inside you uh that you know
and
uh and ideally you know the dream
scenario is something that's all three
of those or or at least two of those
things you know like but but it's one of
those that pretty rare
it's yeah it's it's certainly especially
the idea
good for the wallet and good for the
soul is a far more common
uh combo than the idea of something that
happens to also by dumb luck be high
profile or which is going to benefit
from
a big marketing push or whatever which
would be the good for the career that
part's the one that's the least in your
control
um sure you know you can't negotiate for
better career
positioning basically whereas you can at
least negotiate for
better pay or better rights or something
like that but
yeah i feel like the the the
pay plus sole is probably generally
pretty difficult to do
across industries again like that that
across the board
a lot of people don't get to make those
choices like i took a huge pay cut to
work at santa monica studio but
i love it like i'm infinitely happier
with my professional life
doing what i'm doing now than i was with
what i was doing a year ago like much
more creatively fulfilled
like it's very good for my soul good for
my career yeah also because that's the
direction that i
was working ahead in is is writing
fiction i think i probably will
try to end up directing one day i don't
see myself directing triple a but i
think i'll probably try to do like a
like an indie game maybe a dlc somewhere
but that's like 20 years away
you've got to win and i just really
enjoy it
i think like no i'm saying why 20 years
away why not
i love that you assumed he was
questioning your ambition why would you
want to be a director
um so i do um have a habit of thinking
in a way that's a little bit too black
and white with
your defense wait up my apologies but in
your defense you reacted
very well considering you thought that
was a shitty comment
yeah like like i feel like i just love
it why on earth would you direct that's
a that's a great question troy did you
take any offense to it
i would say first to go [ __ ] yourself
and then i would follow that up with no
i mean
and also do you mean like creative
direct or are you talking about like uh
um would you want to focus more just
like on the
um like narrative director or cinematic
direct
no i think creative direct i think the
whole thing the whole shebang um
well there's some people that that are
creative directors that then bring in a
performance it would depend what that
role means at whatever
studio but also at my experience at the
time so when i say 20 years away it's
because i
i do have a habit of being very black
and white about timelines and even if uh
employers don't require it if i don't
feel like i have the
the things lined up the accomplishments
that i wanted to set before applying for
something like that i won't do it
so i'll be like i want to make sure i
have experience with this and this and
this and that i've done this thing and
then i've tried this before i would even
try to do something like that
directing a video game in 20 years maybe
it won't take that long
but i could see it taking me a while
um i don't know how many 20 27 year old
directors there are probably a number
well if you if you look at indie games
as
like that probably the majority i mean
you know
if you're just sitting and making a game
i mean look and look at how many
brilliant games have been made
by folks under that conditions you know
the the the ftls and the
thomas was alones and you know all you
all
only what is possible yeah you can only
perform up to the level that you're
required
i think genova was i think probably
genova probably would have been 25
26 when he made flour sure really well
because
i was i was 24 when i still had to be
pretty young with fez right
i would imagine similar yeah exactly
basically if you're not directing by the
end of this year you're a slacker
i am very happy being a writer like
that's the thing that i've like already
very candidly spoken about is like i'm
not trying to get promoted
and i know that like a lot of people
often are they like want promotions and
i'm like i'm not
very happy being a writer very happy
writing stuff
i'm i'm good i don't need to move up any
ranks here don't need to tell my manager
what's my plan going forward it's a fine
line
i think you're good i don't think you
have this problem but it's worth saying
just so that
it's said that it can be a fine line
between feeling like
i'm not in a rush i have ambitions but
i'm not trying to be this cutthroat
monster that's
you know looking to achieve them at all
costs but at the same time recognizing
that
it won't happen until you make that push
these things
and again i'm not very good at that yeah
i'm not trying to imply that i think
that that's your problem
but it but some people wait too long and
they yeah you do need to be really
explicit about what you want where you
want to go for sure that's the thing
people get passed over
for promotions or job opportunities all
the time and then they think
here's here's an example i have a friend
who i
um i have to be very
sort of vague i don't wanna i don't
wanna just say you have a friend
yeah i have a friend who i recommended
for a position
and they didn't have a lot of experience
with this type of position but they are
very talented and they have a lot of
very adjacent very very relevant
experience that's just
one degree off of the thing that because
because a friend said
i'm looking a different friend said i'm
looking for somebody who can do x
do you know anyone and i basically was
like well i know someone who i think
could do it
uh let me connect you guys so when when
the candidate
uh submitted and then they had you know
you know their
their meeting and whatnot and then
ultimately they decided not to move
forward
i spoke to the person that i had put for
and i said hey what happened and their
takeaway
was oh well you know they really wanted
somebody who had experience
directly with the thing that they were
looking for and i obviously don't have
that so it's all good
then i asked the other person what was
your take on it and they said
um the person was obviously super
talented and they didn't have the direct
experience
and i was really hoping that they would
say let me prove it to you
let me let me let me show you that i
know i don't have this experience
like they didn't fight for it at all
they basically immediately were like
no worries you know you you should find
someone that you're looking for and i
thought
this is a really interesting case study
where they they were a lot closer to
this job than they think
if they had projected just a little bit
more hunger they would have had
they could have maybe gotten in the door
and it wasn't manipulative it wasn't a
scenario of like
there's unstated questions on the test
kind of thing
i think it was just you're obviously
talented but i don't
you're not really communicating that you
want this
enough to overcome the lack of prior
experience but but if you spoke up and
were like
i will prove it to you but maybe they
didn't want it because they weren't
experienced that's the thing that i tend
to get into is like i'm like i don't
want to do this because i'm like not
ready to yet like i mean not wanting to
get promoted where i work right now is
because i don't want to manage people
i've done that
and i don't want to do it in this
context like i just want to write the
video game i want to learn
i have so much to learn aaa game
development is a big thing there are
like 400 people i work with and i want
to know how they do everything i want to
like sit in the booth with the sound
engineer and be like what do you do
you just go through all of that and like
i don't need very little people right
now
can i i i love that approach
and i think that it will serve you well
um steven spielberg
any director yeah um
this his documentary is really great on
hbo and he says
i direct directors and yeah you've
i love that because i walked out on set
for shadow of war
and i was like okay i need to know what
everything does i need a captain on his
ship understands every screw
um and
and i went out there going i'm gonna be
the one that knows how to do everything
i need to make sure these people believe
that i should be in this position and
they trust me to do this
and what i realized is that after
especially working with
some incredibly accomplished directors
um those are the people that are like i
don't know what you think
but it's it's never a from a position of
they're afraid of what you might find
out that they don't know
they're just like i don't know what that
that guy if you want to find out what
that thing does
that's the person she is the one that is
responsible for that
what i do is this but yeah i'm
definitely not saying that from that
perspective of like being worried about
what anyone thinks of it uh it's a
personal curiosity
oh dude i have the same thing i'm i'm
always the guy and i've always been the
ground still like what does that button
do
i just got fish doing this shoot and i
was like tell me why you're using that
lens
and he's like you want to learn about
anamorphic i'm like yeah i really want
to learn how that works because
so get this now i understand i can take
that knowledge and either just stash it
away and it's fun to play on a trivia
night or i can go
i understand now for my blocking
purposes
if i'm on this side of the camera or if
i'm on the other side of the camera to
be able to go
it won't look right i'd actually we're
because we're on a 75 and it's
anamorphic so we're actually losing half
that's 35
and being able to understand stuff like
that so i love the fascination i had
people at uh ign make fun of me the
writers made fun of me because
i went and i learned how to camera
switch i had a live producer show
um just by asking someone who did that
and i was like can you teach me how to
do it they were like why the [ __ ] are
you doing that it's like i just want to
know how to do it just like i just want
to learn how to do that thing i don't
need it i'm not going to use it but i'd
really like to know how
there is something to be said for
someone who goes
neil druckmann is this way um one of the
reasons why i believe he commands the
respect that he does is because
everybody knows that if push came to
shove
neo could sit down in your desk and do
your job
he is a writer he's an artist he's a
designer he's a
he's done it all and the thing that he
does well
is he goes i just want you to do your
job that's it
i just want you to do it at the best
level that could possibly be i don't
want to do that anymore
but i can if i if i had to that to me is
like
there's so many good stories that that
brings to mind but there
but uh there's a famous german
composer from the mid-20th century named
paul hindemith who
or hindemit if you want to be accurate i
do uh
it it's spelled like hindemith and it's
really hard as an american to not want
to pronounce
the th but it's hinderment and he uh
very famously a master orchestrator you
know his music is
pretty good uh uh he's not considered
one of the kind of
diamond grade classical composers of the
20th century because he was
really appreciated as as an academic and
as a theorist
as a musical thinker um you know
conductor and orchestrator and
his craft was very excellent but very
few people list you know
some of his music is like their favorite
piece of all time but he's very good
and there's a there's a famous story
where
he gets up to conduct an orchestra and
they're in rehearsal in one of the
trombones
and again bearing in mind that his
reputation is as specifically as an
orchestrator he knows how to write for
these instruments very well
um and someone in the trombone raises
their hand and says
you know because classical orchestra
musicians can sometimes be just the
worst
and like like caddy like caddy [ __ ]
mean girls
type like just they they they get this
weird
fan of that that's very funny to me it's
so bizarre but so
so they just decide we don't like this
guy and so the or the one of the tron
bonus goes maestro
uh what would you like me to do it
measure whatever 75
uh this part's not playable i'm afraid
you've written something that the
trombone can't do
and it's like that's a big thing to
throw in front of the orchestra like
that you know it's a big statement to
just drop
in front and put put them on the spot
like wow
and so he very casually walked up
takes the trombone out of their hand
plays it for them hands it back goes i
think it's perfectly doable
and uh walks back to the podium very
very very few conductors could do that
there's a famous there's another related
famous story the great music teacher of
the 20th century
one of the great she's she's she's not
an unsung hero but she's
underappreciated relative to the
shadow she has cast over the world of
classical music was a french teacher
named nadia boulanger
who maintained a like a private uh group
of students in paris
um and she is a legend and some of her
students are like
you know philip glass aaron copeland
like she
was a full-blown legend and was
notoriously brutal you know where she
would say okay
you know uh she'd hand everyone sheet
music of a thing that sounds like this
you know
and it's like and then hand it to them
without playing it and say sing this
but uh a perfect fifth higher
than what's written that kind of thing
just interesting v or sing it backwards
i mean just brutal
every time you tell these kinds of
stories you you make me want to write a
tv pilot about
an orchestra like i don't know what that
is but just like the weird drama
and how different people function and
yeah all the
catty [ __ ] basically yeah i love it
so nadia boulanger
was you know especially coming up in the
essentially like what year was she would
have been born i would think it would be
the late 19th century
uh 1874. let's see
is that correct 1887.
pretty close yeah died 1979. uh
real long life that's confused she um
there's a story
uh where she was you know because she
had developed this
sta this stable of students that you
know all were becoming like the most
noteworthy composers in the world i mean
we're literally talking about people
like philip glass
and aaron copeland uh you know and many
others
she um uh had career opportunities
outside of education every now and again
that she would
and so there was a story i heard where
she was conducting she was invited to
come conduct a thing which is very rare
you know obviously
like we talked about last time there's a
powerful history of misogyny um
in the classical music world so so she
had so there was this story that i'd
heard i wish i
knew what year this was or which
orchestra it was or anything i'll have
to go look it up and see if i can track
down where
because i don't even remember where i
heard this but she got up and she
because of the rigorousness of her
training you know she had these
ears like radar i mean she just a
musician on a level that's
rare like you know dozens probably ever
just superhuman and she gets up to
conduct an orchestra and they're looking
at her and they're like who's this woman
that would dare presume to conduct us so
like
some of the chatter in the back some of
the violas or whomever
string players towards the back are
saying you know
all right you all agree let's like
you'll play half note higher here you'll
have and like intentionally
try to sabotage the rehearsal just
overtly try to [ __ ] her up so that she's
like
this isn't sounding right so it's like
they do it she immediately
taps the podium stops the orchestra and
is like viola 12 and 13 you played a
half step higher in
bar 73 please don't do it again it's
just like like a [ __ ] sniper
straight at them everyone in the
orchestra just like scared shitless like
holy [ __ ] i mean very very few
i couldn't do that i mean that level of
just like it's like it's like yeah it's
like daredevil where her ear just
straight to this space straight to the
right person and just she was also an
alien by the way it was like
she was a robot honestly it was still
impressive it wouldn't surprise me given
the the legendary stories at first
what my one of my private teachers was
one of her last ever
students and told these stories that i
was like i couldn't have survived
let's make the tv show pilot about her
let's do it
about who nadia boulanger yes
she's probably that's an actually
interesting question about if there's
ever been anything made about her
because
she's she's definitely one of these
figures that is spoken about with such
extreme reverence
uh who's largely the average music fan
doesn't know who she is and yet
she really shaped 20th century music
through her students
i unfortunately the matcha tea has let
me know that it is
out oh time it is out time yeah
um so thank you all for joining us this
week this is play watch listen not you
mike bissell
except for mike bethel whose internet
doesn't join us
our next episode is episode 60 which
means we have to go live
we do live episodes every 10 episodes uh
we've not figured out uh time for that
yet
um i will leave a link in the
description uh or if you're listening to
the audio
go on it just sounds like an alarm it
just sounds like you have like a
notification going on
basically when we figured out when we're
gonna do that i will tweet it out um
people being like but i don't want to
sign up to twitter for updates i i won't
make you do that
uh you can just read the tweet you'll
just miss it
someone did also mention that there's
some way for me to like post something
to youtube i don't know how that works
but i'll look into that as well so once
a community there's a feed on youtube
yeah i've never used it before
it's really i don't know yeah i don't
it's very annoying when i see
a post and i think it's like a channel i
subscribe but the one with the cat
videos
yes yeah it is yeah but either way we'll
be live next week um and
we will see you all there thank you for
watching we'll see you then
bye